montmagny and makes her a lieu la drees
c'est là où je suis né et grandi en fait
quel regard on peut avoir sur ses
origines sur 100 comme on dit burt
presse en anglais c'est ça a vraiment un
sens très très concret en fait c'est
l'endroit où on aime
[Musique]
l'idée c'était de montrer un peu tous
les visages de la musique du folklore
arménien donc ce folklore qui a été vu
par plusieurs cerveaux
[Applaudissements]
nous emportons c'est d'essayer de
retrouver le vrai sens l'âme de ce que
les gens voulaient exprimer à l'époque
donc et ça ça n'a pas changé que ce soit
avec les machines ou sans un être humain
il reste un être humain
[Musique]